bonjour jacques lefort bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin avec
nous sur rt france on a montré les
images de cette agression de la
procession à laquelle vous assistiez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
qui s'est passé déjà il faut bien cette
marche pacifique
l'initiative de du diocèse de paris en
présence de l'évêque de paris vit cachée
est effectivement se font partie de la
prison de la roquette ou de l'ancienne
prison de la roquette
où étaient ils ont été détenus et prêter
les gardes républicains pour
reconstituer le parcours des otages le
29 mai 1871 il ya 150 ans pour
commémorer les morts des prêtres les
morts de la garde républicaine de
l'époque pour commémorer no more c'était
une marche totalement pacifique
effectivement il est désavoué tout un
certain moment il ya une tension qui a
monté progressivement au début c'était
bon enfant c'est naturel nous sommes
dans l'est parisien
il y as forcément populaire il ya
forcément
voilà c'est nous sommes très habitués à
cela dans l'est parisien mais un certain
moment il ya eu une attaque violente de
deux individus de pisa d'individus qui
se sont pris à au cortège qui ont pris
les drapeaux français qui ont pris les
bannières des paroissiens des paroisses
nous sommes allés récupérer des drapeaux
tout à fait tout à fait nous avons
vraiment fait attention à l'est
effectivement récupérer ses emblèmes de
la nation public mais sans rendre les
coucous m'importait c'était
effectivement pas facile il ya eu cette
première altercation très forte et
ensuite une deuxième altercation où il a
tout simplement laissé ses militants
extrêmement extrêmement dangereux se
sont mis à envoyer des poubelles à
prendre des tessons de verre des
bouteilles de verre et à les envoyer sur
la foule alors qu'il y avait des
familles et des enfants dans cette foule
et donc effectivement une personne a eu
a hua a été atteint centrale et a dû
être hospitalisé oui cette personne on a
vu son image sur les réseaux sociaux
elle dans quel état est elle cette
personne aujourd'hui c'est une personne
qui est plutôt à gc ca oui c'était en
fait c'était effectivement un adhérent
de l'association mémorielle qui étaient
venus pour assister pacifiquement à
cette réunion et qui effectivement a
s'est interposé cauet qui était voilà
qui a pris ensuite une bouteille au
moment où elle part faire gagner là la
foule
actuellement elle va mieux elle va mieux
on a vu hier puisque vous allez finir la
possession qui a été rompu
donc nous avons eu hier dimanche nous
sommes retournés des otages pour aller
nous recueillir sur le mur ou des
prêtres et les gardes républicains tombé
à signer cette personne allait commencer
une manifestation est forcément encadré
par la police
quel était le dispositif est est ce que
vous avez pu avoir un peu dead de la
part des policiers sur place nous avons
vu un policier qui nous encadrent est
remarquable travail remarquable qui
était bien seul
comment est ce que vous expliquez cette
agressivité et cette violence d'ailleurs
un est-ce que ça s'inscrit selon vous
dans un contexte plus général
je pense qu'il faut se remettre
effectivement la situation du de la
commune de l'époque où il ya certaines
indications qui avaient porté par les
corridas voilà c'était une forme de
volonté de rigueur c'est au nom de
justice sociale qui peut être qu'ils
étaient à l'époque la question a été est
ce que c'est la révolution qui était le
bon outil alors que la république je
veux reconnaître elle était en septembre
1812 1870 d'être proclamé sur les ruines
du second empire suite de ce dont cette
république avait fait les uns des aléas
des élections tout à fait régulière pour
tonner
matière pour signer l'armistice face à
la prusse constatant que la la vie tant
des plus possible et donc ce que la
commune s'est élevé contre contre cette
décision et pour des raisons qui sont
celles de l'époque mais il y avait quand
même fondement antireligieux déjà à
l'époque ce qui est tout à fait désolant
c'est que ce fort anti religieux
persiste jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore
alors que les prêtres sont des gens qui
font un travail remarquable dans les
quartiers au service des paroissiens au
service des personnes les plus fragiles
comme à l'époque d'ailleurs puisque le
perdront les planches à une action
sociale remarquable et reconnu il a été
inondé ses victimes on peut constater
qu'en fait la haine anti religieuse pour
se poursuivre encore de notre jour en
france
ça fait très mal ça fait mal au coeur de
voir que nous avons encore dans ces
situations le diocèse a porté plainte
qu'attendez-vous de de la justice déjà
que éventuellement ce qui est qu'elle
puisse connaître des personnes qui ont
porté atteinte violemment à la tête de
cette manifestation
je crois même qu'il ya eu des crachats
comme ça c'est choquant mais il ya eu
des crachats sur les crêtes
oui il ya eu aussi voilà ces jets de
projectiles il ya eu ces violences
envers les drapeaux envers les notamment
les porte drapeaux féminin c'était d'une
grande lâcheté et je pense
qu'effectivement si on veut par ce geste
fort montrer comporter de cette façon
des siècles en france
donc pour vous c'est vraiment ce cet
événement qui a créé ces tensions c'est
pas ce n'est pas de l'agressivité
spontanée au passage de votre cortège
c'est aux berges ans de en fait il ya eu
un délai les personnes qui étaient sur
le bord du cortège ont vu passer une
cérémonie quel sort attend pour certains
quantifier comme manifestation qui
connut c'était pas du tout cas c'était
juste une manifestation pacifiste pour
honorer les morts de l'église catholique
à paris et est ensuite ce sont
effectivement des personnes qui
naturellement
l anti religieuse et qui se sont
souvenus extrême violence sur la vidéo
il fasciste c'est plus qu'un les
associations mémorielles qui étaient
présents avec leurs drapeaux sont les
mêmes ce sont des associations qui
assistent aux commémorations en mairie
avait résistante tous bords qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite lors des
commémorations guerre mondiale qu'il
traite de tout tout tout positionnement
politique c'était vraiment totalement
pacifistes et cette agression est
justifié merci beaucoup jacques lefort
de nous avoir livré en direct ce matin
votre témoignage sur rt france